This is something you have to see.
For weeks now, right wing media has been going
bananas over Joe Biden not having a press
conference.
Joe Biden has now announced a press conference
for next Thursday.
And now the problem has become it's bad that
Joe Biden announced the press conference so
far in advance.
This is once again proof that you can't please
these people and you shouldn't try to please
these people.
So as a reminder, the day before yesterday
on Fox, big explosive headline, Biden, 54
days without a press conference yesterday
on Fox, Joe Biden, 55 days without a press
conference a few days ago in The Washington
Post, quoting Donald Trump's former press
secretary, Kayleigh McEnany.
Biden isn't doing press conferences because
he's being protected by his staff from unscripted
questions.
Last week, Fox News reporting on the Chicago
Tribune op ed titled How Long Can President
Biden Hide from Real News Conferences?
Earlier last week, Fox News with a big table
with the number of days until the first press
conference for the last 16 presidents.
Last week at the 50 day mark, we got this
stunning report.
President Biden blows off questions from reporters
as he goes 50 days without a formal press
conference.
And then yesterday they announce Joe Biden
is going to do a press conference and now
we get this discussion of suspicion.
Katie, I have to ask, why in the world would
you announce a press conference nine days
from now?
My theory is you announce that morning because
the press is going to come anyway.
Who knows what's going to happen in nine days?
Guys, it's just suspicious.
Why are they announcing the press on?
And so far in advance.
Well, what about the weeks of reporting about
how Biden is terrible because he's not announcing
and doing a press conference, it's truly pathetic.
They will never be happy.
Don't try to make them happy.
Just don't waste your breath.
Don't waste your energy.
And I actually am looking forward to Biden's
press conference.
I look forward to him being asked tough questions
about the things we've been asking about the
border and so many other things.
What's the plan for the 15 dollar minimum
wage?
What's going on with infrastructure?
Do you plan to use budget reconciliation to
get infrastructure done, which we will talk
about later on in today's program?
I'm very much looking forward to it.
We don't have a schedule yet, but it'll be
sometime next Thursday.
And you can bet that I will be live on YouTube,
on Twitch and on Facebook.
In the meantime, weigh in on this faux scandal
about Joe Biden's press conferences by following
us on Instagram at David
Pakman show.